okay so now let's lastly talk about a
recent article on your website about the
UAP task force and Travis Taylor so just
walk us through what is that about what
are your thoughts on that sure so the
UAP task force was yet again one of
those efforts with many names it keeps
evolving name wise and and uh office who
controls them makes it a little bit
frustrating for a researcher but the UAP
task force was an effort to investigate
uh UFOs UAP
and by research and kind of digging into
documents had discovered a couple years
ago it was likely led by a man by the
name of Jay Stratton and that has since
been confirmed but what wasn't really
confirmed was who worked with him now Dr
Travis Taylor who's an incredibly smart
individual I worked with him when I was
producing for History Channel many many
years ago before any of this UFO stuff
had broken with his connection to it and
had produced some shows talk to him you
know throughout the the production of
those really really great individual uh
incredibly intelligent so as word
started to to to to kind of pass that
these names were coming out
Dr Travis Taylor I think and this is
partly a guess decided to come out on
his own accord to reveal that he was
what was called the chief scientist on
The UAP task force now you may not
recognize Dr Taylor's name uh per se but
if you watch the show Skinwalker Ranch
on History Channel wildly popular he's
one of the stars of that show so he's
been involved in TV for a very long time
involved in uh classified programs with
rocketry and stuff like that for a long
time so his name was getting
kind of mixed into the Paranormal
through that show but then all of a
sudden he comes out and goes yeah
essentially the government was paying me
to be the the chief scientist of the UAP
task force it was a huge Revelation that
story was broken by George Knapp so
credit where it's due that had that had
come out through him so when that story
had broke anytime a new name comes out
I'm right there to take that name
connect it to foia requests and start
seeing what you can find and when that
that story broke that's what I did I
took a foia request and was looking for
communications between Dr Travis Taylor
and his work at Redstone Arsenal and the
UAP task force and because again that
those were all provable aspects of his
career we knew where he was in the Army
so if he was doing work with the UAP
task force certainly there were
Communications emails stuff like that
what I received back was highly redacted
yet again that they didn't want to tell
us what was going on between Dr Taylor
and the UAP task force there's an
unknown number of pages that were sent
to the Navy for review and hopeful
release to me so it could be 100 Pages
could be a thousand people I have no
idea they don't want to tell you so I'm
still working on figuring out a number
but that aside I think there were about
28 pages that were released essentially
all of them were redacted but eight
something like that so it was just a
very high percentage of material that
was redacted
same kind of thing where you don't
really know a whole lot of reasons on
why there was some information that was
Exempted because of the deliberative
process and was was considered
deliberative in nature some other you
know redaction citations I won't bore
you to death with but essentially they
just didn't want to tell you
so what you can deduce though from it
was
he was obviously involved so that kind
of solidified all that even though we
kind of knew that already it's it's nice
to have documentation but we also have
other records that indicate essentially
how they viewed themselves in this story
and even though his name was redacted
it's pretty sorry how they viewed
themselves they correct yeah so so one
email that although the name was
redacted it's easy to figure out was
likely written by Jay Stratton he was
the director of the uaptf that's how he
signed on the signature line but they
just redact the name so a lot of times
you you can just deduce who it is
um but in their in their email he was
introducing Travis Taylor to a team we
don't know the entire team number who
the names were but was saying that Dr
Travis Taylor was gonna help make their
mark on history and it was a it was kind
of this inside look that that's what
they felt on the inside that they were
going to be making history running the
UAP task force and so when Taylor was
introduced to everybody that was how Jay
Stratton said it like this is the guy
that's going to help make our mark on
history so it's a very interesting thing
where even though you have all these
redactions it's interesting because you
can start to see the mindset that they
were in that they believed that with the
UAP task force they were going to make
their Mark they were going to change
history in what way I I don't know I
mean we can kind of guess on that but it
is interesting to see that that's what
they believed behind the scenes about
their work in the UAP task force what's
odd to me is that when someone works for
the government especially in this topic
like let's say Eric Davis or at least
allegedly works for the government they
can't do media someone like Travis
Taylor I assume the UAP task force is
related to the government and is working
for the government and then is allowed
to have seasons on the History Channel
about the same topic how does that work
yeah that was a big question mark from
people like me and many many others if
you're doing that work how and you're
working in a classified realm right that
all of that is 100 confirmed there's
there's no arguing that so Dr Taylor was
involved in highly classified material
and and working on that at the same time
working on a History Channel show called
Skinwalker Ranch that was in the same
paranormal genre uh imagine if someone
was a CIA spy and that secret classified
and then they go and then they're an
actor in a show where they play a CIA
spy and that's completely allowed and
not only is it once like it's a major
role and it's several episodes and then
it gets renewed for Seasons I think that
that was a concern by many of the public
but also within the cast of Skinwalker
Ranch and they had done a behind the
scenes interview which I saw
um on their uh uh uh it's like a paywall
area that they have for the for the show
and they were all talking after this
broke that Dr Taylor was
kind of doubling if you want to call it
that I mean he was head of the UAP
taskbar working on highly classified
information within the government but at
the same time working with them on the
ranch investigating UFOs and other
paranormal events
how could you not tell the people that
you're working with on this TV show hey
by the way
I'm working for the government too which
some of you may think is involved in
this massive cover-up I'm with them
right now I'm working for them too but
I'm not going to tell you it's a really
bizarre situation and on top of that I
questioned how do you not know like how
do you how is that possible that
somebody who's doing the classified work
for for the government doing the the
Consulting work for the UAP task force
uh UAP task force which was official
um so you're doing all that official
work but then doing this TV show on the
side there's a lot of questions there
how much information was Dr Taylor
taking from that show and giving it to
the government potentially without their
knowledge now I'm not trying to create
any conspiracies there but those are
those are viable questions to ask when
you're doing such double work
um and I think that those have not been
answered so going back to that foia
request that reveals some of these
emails you start to piece together
some of those answers not all but some
of them where you can kind of see
Stratton was getting funding to get Dr
Travis Taylor to fly to Washington so
you start putting things together in a
big timeline which is what I've done and
it's a massive massive undertaking in
itself but every time these documents
come in like the the uh Dr Travis Taylor
documents and so on you can take dates
or at least some idea of a date and put
it on that timeline and say Dr Travis
was you know going to be flown to
Washington DC to meet with Jay Stratton
for UAP task force business but then you
can start to like when you really expand
the timeline see where they were and
what they were doing on Skinwalker Ranch
who what where when why all that kind of
stuff you just put all these pieces of
the puzzle together so
um going back to your question though it
really does Boggle the mind on how all
that is just kind of okay it's not a
problem to do all of that because you
would think that it wouldn't but in this
case it was absolutely fine
it seems likely that I'll be able to
speak to Travis for the podcast so I can
ask him any questions that you have and
any questions in the audience if you
have you can comment below apparently
Travis has a PHD in Optical engineering
so it would be great to speak to him
about some of the physics a question I
have is when people say that UFOs break
the laws of physics like how do you know
that they break the laws because do you
have enough data to even state that but
anyway I'm looking forward to that and I
appreciate that you've spent now three
hours maybe even totaled three and a
half hours with me I'm PR I'm far more
like over text just working out this
project thank you man thank you for
spending so much time with me of course
I hope it was okay oh it was wonderful I
I it was an honor to be here May you ask
excellent questions I've looked forward
to the interview since we first talked
about it however many months ago and uh
yeah I'm glad we were able to do it and
hopefully the answers made a little bit
of sense I hope that it lived up to the
hype of course that didn't look uh you
it's always fun to be interviewed by
someone who asks intelligent great
questions and you could tell by your
interviews that's uh that's who you are
that's a channel you've built I have a
lot of respect for that so uh so so
kudos to you and and wish you all the
best and I hope this uh I hope my side
lived up to uh being asked uh to be on
the show so thank you for that
thank you man you just watched a clip
from the theories of everything channel
for the full video and all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy